contaminated ways from the side of the
toxic trained derailment in East
Palestine Ohio is now being hauled to
hazardous waste disposal facilities near
Detroit Michigan and Houston Texas but
during a packed town hall on Friday
environmental Advocate Aaron Brockovich
warned of long-term Health impacts and
devastating damages from the fiery
February 3rd derailment Roxanna saberi
has more now from East Palestine
at a town hall in East Palestine
environmental activist Aaron Brockovich
told residents Friday night to keep
calling for the truth every Community
I've been going to for 30 years
it's the same runaround since the Train
derailed on February 3rd and spewed
toxic materials residents have reported
an array of new health problems though
authorities say Arn Municipal Water
tests have not detected dangerous levels
of chemicals they're worried because
they've got
coughs and respiratory problems
Brockovich says This Disaster reminds
her of her own battle in the 1990s when
she discovered that a utility company
was contaminating the groundwater in
Hinckley California sickening residents
there's so many unanswered questions and
they know that this isn't the last of
this conversation what advice do you
have stay tuned to the environment on
Thursday a preliminary NTSB report found
that sensors alerted the crew of the
Norfolk Southern train to an overheated
wheel bearing and that they tried to
slow down but 38 rail cars derailed just
a mile from here hazardous materials
from the train derailment seeped into
this Creek which runs through the heart
of East Palestine where we are now Crews
have been cleaning up for weeks but you
can still see chemical sheens on the
surface
the rail operator says it's committed to
cleaning up and that it's distributed
six and a half million dollars in
assistance to affected residents and the
Ohio Department of Health is ramping up
services at its free medical clinic to
people in nearby towns like Negley just
a few miles south so how often do you
come outside lately not often just
because of the chemicals that's where
Bridget piles lives I'm afraid of the
chemicals coming here and the after
effects anxiety and uncertainty she says
are Rippling far beyond the derailment
across the region and into the future
for CBS Saturday morning Roxanna saberi
East Palestine Ohio